[Musique]
apollo il verra t-on équipements et le
cas sera un morceau push marines et
wasquehal il prendra ton âme sol qui et
puis je fais tu as qui est dit
[Musique]
avant il y avait trois chaman maintenant
ils sont beaucoup les pèlerins ceux qui
sont venus pour un service de prières
par là
oh
[Musique]
on
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue en direct
sur rt france pour 1h30 d'émission nous
décryptons comme chaque soir du lundi au
jeudi à l'essentiel de l'information
avec nos invités bien évidemment tenu à
bonne distance et nos reporters une
émission consacrée à la crise du
coronavirus en france et dans le monde
la france se prépare au déconfinement le
gouvernement vient de présenter sa carte
montrant les régions où le virus circule
encore une carte avec trois couleurs
jaune vert et rouge
ils sont 35 en rouge la plupart en
région parisienne et dans le nord-est
une identification des zones touchées
pour remettre les français au travail
sans déclencher une deuxième vague de
l'épidémie
cet après midi et loire philippe a
également consulté les partenaires
sociaux alors que les chiffres de
l'économie sont alarmants le pib a chuté
de 5,8 pour cent pour le seul premier
trimestre côté sanitaire le coronavirus
a fait 289 victimes aujourd'hui
[Musique]
conséquences de cette pandémie
la menace d'une récession économique
historique dans le monde se précise la
zone euro souffre le chômage bondit en
allemagne tandis que les économies
française et espagnole se sont contracté
à un rythme inédit au premier trimestre
avec un très fort chute de très forte
chute de leur pib
côté inflation la baisse des prix de
l'énergie qu'on pense généralement la
hausse des produits alimentaires
[Musique]
3 millions 800 nouveaux cas demandeurs
d'allocations chômage sur une semaine
aux états unis l'amérique reste le foyer
majeur de la pandémie avec près de
soixante deux mille décès à new york les
pompes funèbres sont débordés en russie
le chef du gouvernement en mirage michou
steen a annoncé être atteint du
coronavirus il est remplacé
temporairement par le premier vice
premier ministre
andrei beloussov
[Musique]
et on débute avec la carte de france des
voiliers il y à quelques instants par le
ministère la santé et trois couleurs à
retenir les départements en rouge en
jaune ou en verre trente cinq
départements sont affichés en rouge sur
la première carte du gouvernement cela
veut dire qu'ils ne répondent pas aux
critères pour appliquer toutes les
mesures pour un déconfinement le 11 mai
il sera plus stricte voire repoussées en
jaune à la situation n'est pas critique
mais reste à surveiller de près à
l'inversé les habitants en zone verte
pour entamer un retour à une vie moins
contraignante dès le 11 mai une
différenciation des départements avec
trois critères le taux de cas de
contamination dans la population le
nombre de places disponibles à l'hôpital
la possibilité de tester rapidement la
population est des cartes qui sont
susceptibles d'évoluer comme
l'expliquent le ministre de la santé
nous avons maintenu des zones orange qui
sont des zones qui ont vocation à
basculer d'ici au 11 mai ou en verre
c'est la pression épidémique se réduit
parce que vous restez chez vous si le
les lits de réanimation arrive à
retrouver un peu plus d'amplitude ou a
basculé en rouge si d'aventuré la
circulation du virus devaient
s'accentuer ou aussi il y avait à
nouveau ou encore trop de malades dans
les services de réanimation
donc ces cartographies encore une fois
ne sont que des indicateurs qui guident
les décisions
ils sont affinés par d'autres
indicateurs un autre d'ailleurs viendra
s'ajouter à ce que je viens de vous
présenter à partir du 11 mai nous serons
en mesure de vous présenter les nombre
de tests qui sont réalisés par
territoire si d'aventuré on devait
s'apercevoir que le nombre de malades
devient supérieure à ce que nous avions
prévu de pouvoir tester sur un
territoire donné
ça pourrait être une information
importante et nous la communiquer
aurions mais sachez que nous mettons
tout en oeuvre pour préparer notre pays
dans la perspective du 11 mai nous
rappelons l'objectif être capable de
tracer toutes les personnes
symptomatique leur cas contactez d'être
capable d'isoler les personnes qui
peuvent présenter des symptômes ou qui
sont susceptibles de transmettre la
maladie de manière à protéger les
français et pour en parler nous sommes
avec jean paul hamon il est président de
l'association des médecins de france est
médecin généraliste
jean paul hamon merci d'être avec nous
en direct sur rt france alors en tant
que médecin est ce que vous saluer cette
stratégie de différencier les
départements pour éviter une seconde
vague ont écouté que le département soit
soit vers roux je range ça change pas
grand chose c'est à dire qu' il va
falloir que les médecins généralistes
soient soient mobilisés pour identifier
et répertorier les personnes positives
de façon à ce qu'on puisse identifier
également les personnes contactées de
façon à ou à confiner rapidement les les
personnes qu'on doit qu'on doit protéger
pour éviter la contagion ont donc dans
tous les départements les médecins
généralistes seront la même aura la même
attitude là la vraie question c'est est
ce qu'on aura le droit d'en dans deux
trois quatre semaines le droit de
changer de région de passer d'une rouge
à une jaune ou d'une jonah hill verte et
à versements donc la question et c'est
la seule que tous les français se posent
en ce moment en tout cas est ce qu'avec
cette stratégie là il y a quand même un
risque de deuxième vague cette deuxième
réacteur redouté et quelles en seraient
les causes meilleur il n'y a pas de
deuxième bague il ya une seule et même
pas glas actuellement on à freiner
l'épidémie grâce au confinement
on a réussi à soulager les hôpitaux
grâce au confinement a soulagé les lits
de réanimation qui sont quand même un
flux tendu avec du personnel qui n'est
pas extensible à l'infini
donc il fallait absolument diminuer la
pression sur les lits de réanimation et
contrôler le
le redémarrage et contrôler leur
démarrage de l'épidémie
parce que forcément avec le confinement
avec le déconfinement même si c'est un
déconfinement extrêmement prudent il va
y avoir de nouveaux cas qui vont qui
vont se produire
et c'est cela qu'il faudra identifier
contrôler confiné et pour éviter que de
nouveaux les hospitaliers soit soient
surchargées et c'est pour ça que le
système doit doit faire preuve là cette
fois ci de cette efficacité parce que
les médecins généralistes cette fois ci
seront protégés avec des masques sans
doute j'espère pour des lunettes et des
charlotte et des blues pour ce qui
concerne les prélèvements et puis ainsi
on pourra confiné l'excellente a limité
l'extension de l'épidémie et éviter que
l'hôpital ne soit débordé alors
justement concernant la tension des
capacités hospitalières
est-ce qu'il est encore nécessaire de
déplacer des malades dans différentes
régions voire les départements en rouge
est ce que ce serait une solution de
déplacer les malades dans des
départements en zone jaune ou vert par
exemple
non mais là maintenant il n'y a plus il
n'y a plus aucune zone qu'ils soient
qu'ils soient débordés en réanimation
tout tout les lits devraient tous les
lits de réanimation ont été
on était soulagés même si c'est quand
même extrêmement extrêmement tendue donc
là il est plus question de déménager des
délits des personnes en réanimation
d'une région à une autre
alors en tout cas il est question des
tests vous vous en parliez tout à
l'heure c'est un des derniers paramètres
de la capacité des départements s'est
testé détecter les personnes en contact
avec le virus dans les ces fameux
département zone rouge
on le voit bien des régions avec une
forte population s est est massif est ce
qu'ils sont très concrètement réalisable
aujourd'hui je pense que oui ça va ça va
être réalisable c'est dans tous les cas
c'est réalisable en pc ces prélèvements
qu'on fait dans les narines
enfin dans le brabant le fin fond parce
que si on fait un test juste dans les
tailles dont on a des négatifs qui sont
faux mais ce qu'on attend surtout cesser
dès que qu'on valide les tests sanguins
à ceux qui vont permettre de savoir si
si les gens ont fait le la maladie ou
pas parce que n'oublions pas que
beaucoup de personnes sont touchées sans
faire aucun symptôme
alors une autre question pour pour
terminer qui interpelle aussi sur le
virus et cette étude génétique menée par
l'institut pasteur qui laisse entendre
que la diffusion de l'épidémie en france
serait très peu liés à des cas importés
de chine ou d'italie une troisième
souche à l'origine pour l'instant
inconnues expliquerait cette forte
diffusion de l'épidémie dans l'hexagone
qu'est ce qu'il faut comprendre qu
est-ce que vous pouvez nous expliquer à
ce sujet là j'étais j'ai été un peu
surpris quand j'ai lu ça ce matin
effectivement est ce que c est ce que
c'est quand même pas une mutation du
virus est ce que c'est pas quand même
c'est quand même là la coïncidence est
quand même troublante l'italie l'italie
aurait des cas importés
et nous on n'aurait pas de cas importés
moi je suis persuadé que ce qui s'est
passé en rhône alpes auvergne
ou quand même on a assisté à une flambée
de cas à parti quinze jours après le
match contre de la juventus contre
contrôlions avec en plus le quelques
jours plus tard où quelques jours et
quelques jours plus tard le match lyon
saint-etienne qui a de nouveau brasser
la population de rhône alpes auvergne
donc il ya eu trois grands matchs de
foot dans cette région et et quinze
jours après le match mais lotus turin il
ya eu une flambée des cas on a le
problème ce ne sont pas les cas de la
contamine montjoie qui des
contamines-montjoie qui on est et qui
ont été à l'origine de cette de cette
flambée est donc incontestablement c'est
quinze jours après le match juventus
turin
donc je comprendrais mal faudrait quand
même aller voir du côté de rhône alpes
auvergne si c'est quand même pas le même
virus que le virus italia ce que je
pense merci beaucoup jean paul hamon
d'avoir répondu à nos questions je
rappelle que vous êtes président de
l'association des médecins de france est
médecin généraliste
le gouvernement a donc opté pour une
classification des départements en trois
catégories pour adapter le déconfinement
réalités locales à les détails de cette
méthode dans l'image
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on
ou pas
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
oh
mon
tout
[Musique]
on
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
à partir du 11 mai le premier ministre a
appelé les français à éviter autant que
possible tout déplacement hors de son
département il sera néanmoins possible
de se déplacer sans motif familial ou
professionnel impérieux uniquement si la
distance parcourue ne dépassent pas les
100 km la vie des français sera donc
différente en zone rouge zone verte ou
en zone jaune alors assistons à la mise
en place de petites frontières dans le
pays c'est l'objet de notre face à face
[Musique]
et pour en débattre alexis bachelet
conseiller municipal de la ville de
colombes et laurent jacomelli porte
parole du rassemblement national
messieurs bonsoir merci de nous avoir
rejoints en direct sur rt france alors
finalement l'instauration de ces
différentes zones dans le pays est ce
que pour vous on peut comparer cela
cette stratégie à la mise en place de
petites frontières à l'intérieur du pays
laurent jacobellis
oui c'est un peu le cas c'est à dire que
le gouvernement a pris une décision qui
est d une fine et étape par étape zone à
moins de risques
après zone à moindre risque c'est qu'il
nous paraît être une bonne solution même
si dans les faits il va falloir nous
expliquer comment quand on travaille
dans un département vert ont pas dans un
conte habite dans un département où l'on
fait etc etc mais ça valide l'idée que
l'importation du virus par un individu
infecté est possible d'un département à
l'autre d'une zone de 100 km à une autre
et bien évidemment d'un pays à l'autre
et c'est david la limite de la logique
du gouvernement c'est à dire que il
ils appliquent des frontières à
l'intérieur de la france mais
malheureusement il refuse de les
appliquer alex
d'ailleurs est ce que vous savez que cet
après midi et ce soit ont atterri à
roissy des avions provenant des états
unis d'helsinki d'abou dhabi de rome de
rome est d'abidjan
aucun contrôle sanitaire pour aucun des
passagers
et si parmi eux arrivent des passagers
avec le virus avec une nouvelle forme de
virus et qui peuvent eux entrer
librement à roissy comment on pourra
expliquer à des français que eux ne
peuvent pas circuler librement
les français sont prêts à faire cet
effort mais ils sont prêts à le faire si
l'effort est national logique est
appliquée aussi aux frontières de notre
territoire alors alexis bachelet ce que
vous comprenez ce paradoxe qui a voulu
souligner laurent jacot bélie à savoir
on n'a pas fermé les frontières
nationales
mais aujourd'hui au fond on empêche les
français de se déplacer à l'intérieur du
péri du pays
illogique un donc pour vous le rend
jacomelli qu'est ce que vous en pensez
alexis bachelet je crois que c'est
difficile de raisonner de la manière jeu
par analogie entre des frontières
nationales
est ce qu'on est en train de vivre
aujourd'hui c'est à dire un maintien du
confinement mais avec progressivement un
retour de la de la circulation avec des
règles extrêmement extrêmement je dirais
précise et et différenciés en fonction
du territoire national c'est évident que
à partir du moment où on a des
territoires qui sont moins touchés que
d'autres
c'est assez logiquement que le
gouvernement essaye d'établir de
rétablir un mode de fonctionnement plus
souple que dans d'autres territoires qui
bien sont maintenus dans un confinement
plus plus strictes plus rigide
parce que la circulation du virus est
encore relativement importante
donc moi ça ne me choque pas qu'on soit
dans cette logique là peut-être que ce
qui est étonnant et là je donnerais à ta
à laurent jacot berry de son
raisonnement c'est que il aurait
peut-être fallu fermer les frontières
nationales avant
c'est vrai que dès qu'on a su qu'une
épidémie se propager en chine
il aurait fallu sans doute prendre des
mesures d'abord fermer les voies
aériennes et ensuite probablement
rétablir des contrôles aux frontières et
fermé les frontières à partir du moment
où il était avéré que l'épidémie ne
respectait pas ces digues frontières et
qu'elle était en train de circuler non
seulement à travers la chine met ensuite
en europe l'italie pays voisins et donc
je pense que le gouvernement français
et j'ai pas forcément les clés pour
comprendre cette décision a tardé à
fermer les frontières et il est
évidemment logique aujourd'hui qu'on
soit dans un mode de déconfinement par
territoire parce qu'il n'y a pas de
raison de maintenir tout le monde au
même degré de confinement compte tenu du
fait que dans certains territoires le
virus est très peu présent ou quasiment
absent alors un laurent jacot bélie la
différence de vilains des français dans
chacune des régions va forcément être
être différente en fonction qu'il soit
en jaune rouge ou en zone verte
est ce que cette situation selon vous
peut engendrer des crispations dans le
dans le pays qu'elles soient sociales ou
économiques
oui je crois que les français et ils
l'ont montré au cours des dernières
semaines sont prêts à faire des
sacrifices ils le font avec bonne
volonté plutôt naturellement même s'il
ya des inconvénients de leur vie de tous
les jours
il accepte de remplir une attestation
pour aller faire leurs courses ou aller
à la pharmacie
ils ont le jouet du jeu globalement cet
effort
ils ne le feront une continueront à le
faire si et seulement si toutes les
conditions sont remplies pour que ces
efforts soient utiles oui on n'acceptera
dans les zones rouges de faire plus
d'efforts que dans les zones vert mais a
besoin de vrais arbres mais à une seule
condition c'est que le gouvernement soit
à la hauteur des enjeux et ce qui fait
un peu peur c'est qu'on a l'impression
qu'il a fixé une date le 11 mai comme un
totem et qu'il veut derrière que
l'intendance suive
mais ce dont on s'est aperçu en france
malheureusement avec cette équipe là
c'est que la tendance ne suivait pas or
est-ce qu'il y aura assez masse que le
11 mai
rien n'est moins sûr est ce qu'on aura
assez de test pour tester tout le monde
notamment ceux qui vont travailler
rien n'est moins sûr est-ce qu'on va
continuer à s'entêter à vouloir ouvrir
les écoles alors conseille maintenant
que probablement le coc vide a un effet
sur les plus jeunes qui peut être très
grave
bref les français sont prêts à faire des
efforts mais ce qui est inquiétant c'est
que ceux qui doivent les soutenir qui
doit créer les conditions de réussite de
l'effort eux ne sont pas à la hauteur
mentent aux français on l'a vu à l'aise
avec les masses et les infantilise donc
qu'il ya beaucoup à craindre et vous
parler d'économie moi je suis dans les
bouches du rhône
il ya un certain nombre de restaurateurs
il ya un certain nombre de gens qui
vivent du tourisme
aujourd'hui notre département est classé
en zone orange ils n'ont aucune date de
sortie de crise
donc ils ne savent pas à quelle sauce
ils vont être mangés le 11 mai puis
ensuite avant l'été vous comprenez bien
que ce n'est pas possible de maintenir
une activité en l'état qu'il ya un
manque de logistique un manque de
préparation et un manque de
planification
les français font un effort il accepte
les conséquence yb le montrer ils sont
pour la plupart exemplaire mais
l'encadrement
malheureusement ne suit pas alexis
bachelet est ce que dans votre
département vous êtes dans les
hauts-de-seine les français
ne pourrait pas jouer le jeu si
finalement et bien il n'y avait pas de
règles assez clair alors alexis bachelet
peu de petits problèmes techniques qui
nous a quittés en attendant qu'il
revienne je me tourne vers vous laurent
jacobellis donc vous lisiez des français
qui ne pourraient voilà alexis bachelet
qui a un problème technique donc des
français qui ne joueraient pas le jeu et
vous le disiez j'ai pas dit ça et j'ai
dit qu'on prend un risque pour l'instant
que joue exemple aryenne de manière
exemplaire le jeu pour la plupart voilà
alors le voilà alexis bachelet est
revenu avec nous alors est ce que vous
craignez alexis d'acheter dans votre
département
que des français finalement s'ils n'ont
pas une vision suffisamment claire ne
respectent pas les consignes prévu par
le gouvernement bat d'abord je pense
qu'il faut quand même saluer globalement
le civisme et le sens de responsabilité
de nos compatriotes qui quasiment dès le
début du confinement ont respecté les
consignes gouvernementales et avant même
d'être confiné avait commencé à
respecter les gestes barrière
aujourd'hui effectivement la durée du
confinement rend cette situation de plus
en plus inconfortable
il faut que le gouvernement soit le plus
clair possible dans les décisions qui
seront prises notamment effectivement en
direction des activités économiques qui
sont aujourd'hui à l'arrêt et
extrêmement touchée et dont on craint
d'ailleurs pour certaines activités
qu'elle soit vraiment en danger et c'est
vrai que le tourisme dans ces
activités-là fait partie des activités
qui sont gravement empêcher contrainte
avec évidemment toute la partie
restauration hôtellerie
lorient - il continue à partir du moment
où le gouvernement ne sait pas comment
l'épidémie va continuer à vivre sa vie
edouard philippe la digue a été
relativement clair là dessus
il va falloir qu'on vivent avec le virus
donc ça veut dire que vivre avec ça ne
sera pas revenir à la situation d'avant
le confinement
ça sera continuer à vivre
avec des contraintes extrêmement forte
plus forte dans certains territoires
plus fort sur certaines activités et je
pense que aujourd'hui il faut que le
gouvernement communique de manière
extrêmement régulière extrêmement clair
au fur et à mesure que la situation
évoluera avec des indicateurs pour
pouvoir essayer de donner une plus
grande visibilité non seulement aux
activités économiques mais également à
l'ensemble de nos compatriotes qui
aujourd'hui c'est vrai sont plongés dans
lente dans l'anxiété est dans le doute
parce qu'il n'y a pas vraiment de
visibilité sur la manière dont les
prochaines semaines vont se dérouler il
nous reste quelques secondes laurent
jacot billy pour conclure on sait que le
gouvernement compte beaucoup sur sur les
lazy les élus locaux
est-ce qu'on va pas faire des petits
états dans l'état finalement où chacun
va gérer avec ses moyens à sa manière
sur son territoire la situation encore
heureux que le dévouement de beaucoup
d'élus locaux est venu se substituer à
la compétence et à la préparation du
gouvernement il faudrait pas d'ailleurs
que le suédois filip ou que le président
de la république qui commencent à
comprendre que leurs mensonges du début
pourrait leur revenir en effet boomerang
après la fin de la crise essaye de faire
porter toutes les responsabilités aux
maires en leur demandant de protéger nos
concitoyens se leur en donner les moyens
vous savez on sortira de cette crise du
coronavirus qu'effectivement si tout le
monde joue le jeu d'abord le
gouvernement
il faut protéger des français ça veut
dire des masques et des tests il faut
arrêter maintenant à nous mentir arrêté
de tourner autour du pot
le gouvernement n'a pas été capable de
le faire il ne l'est toujours pas il
faut accélérer là dessus deuxièmement
deuxièmement il faut protéger les
passants aux frontières et troisièmement
protéger nos enfants en le faisant
rentrer à l'école qu'en septembre
voilà les premiers gestes à faire à part
ça c'est de la littérature
alex image fait quelques secondes pour
conclure non mais écoutez je pense que
aujourd'hui on sait il ya des choses
qu'on maîtrise
il faut respecter les gestes barrière il
faut équiper les gens en masse qu il
faut augmenter le nombre de tests
ça c'est des choses qui doivent être
faites le plus rapidement possible ça
aurait dû être fait avant
mais bon aujourd'hui on sait que ça doit
être fait et puis pour le reste il va
pour le reste je pense qu'il faudra
qu'on vivent avec une épée de damoclès
autour de notre tête c'est le risque
d'une deuxième vague d'une part et
d'autre part le fait d'être obligé de
continuer à respecter un certain nombre
de règles pour limiter au maximum la
contagion et les victimes faut le
rappeler quand même que on est a déjà
près de 25 mille morts et ça n'est
malheureusement pas encore terminée
merci beaucoup monsieur d'avoir été en
direct avec nous sur rt france alexis
bachelet et ex députée ps des
hauts-de-seine et conseiller municipal
de la ville de colombes avec vous
laurent jacobellis porte parole du
rassemblement national
voici le dernier bilan en france liées
au coït 19 le pays déplore aujourd'hui
24 1376 décès la direction générale de
la santé a annoncé ces dernières 24
heures une hausse du nombre de morts
avec 339 nouveau dessert on relève on
relève par ailleurs une baisse du nombre
de personnes en réanimation avec 188
patients en main 45e jours de
confinement donc en france avec plus de
41000 contraventions depuis le 17 mars
dernier la seine-saint-denis affiche des
statistiques largement supérieur à la
moyenne nationale
elle les habitants dénoncent une
politique gouvernementale qui
privilégierait dans les quartiers
populaires une réponse policière à la
crise sanitaire sur place lille afin
amouzou avec lionel girard 17 % de taux
de verbalisation qu'on 5,9 pour cent au
niveau national de file début du
confinement si vous êtes contrôlés en
seine saint denis vous avez trois fois
plus de risque d'être verbalisé que
partout ailleurs sur le territoire
français comment expliquer de telles
disparités
les habitants de la seine-saint-denis
serait-il moins disciplinés la
répression policière plus importante
nous sommes allés poser la question aux
habitants de saint denis je m'interroge
à savoir si des fois sur le 9 3
s'il n'y a pas un problème de faciès
moi je suis passé dix fois vingt fois
devant les services de police rien je
pense pas que celles liées au racisme
la majorité des gens ici elle respecte
confinement il ya quelques mois après il
ya des jeunes nous des gens qui n'ont
rien à [ __ ]
donc il en a rien à [ __ ] avant ils en
ont rien à [ __ ] mais non c'est tout
j'explique cela par le seul fait que les
gens ils sont pas disciplinés
ici il ya des gens qui vivent 10 au 12
personnes dans un petit petite pièce ils
sont obligés de sortir de respirer un
petit peu je regrette si je peux me
permettre
les écarts un policier qui parfois vous
au delà de leurs compétences et au delà
de leurs fins d'un côté humain ce nombre
élevé de contravention n'a pas échappé à
la procureure du département et parmi
les facteurs qui pourraient justifier un
tel écart avec la moyenne nationale
la magistrate évoque une population très
jeune une densité très importante
un habitat qui rend difficile de rester
chez soi à plusieurs des jeunes
verbaliser notamment en bas des
immeubles et parfois même à plusieurs
reprises et enfin le trafic de
stupéfiants qui n'a pas cessé
des contrôles policiers des
contraventions comme seule réponse à la
population pour madjid messaoudene
conseiller municipal à saint denis
le gouvernement a délibérément décidé de
laisser le champ libre à la police pour
gérer le confinement la seule forme
d'état convoi en seine saint denis
pendanx c'est pareil de confinement mais
en fait c'est la formule répressive de
la police qui est là effectivement non
pas pour aider à ce que le confinement
se passe le mieux possible mais pour
verbaliser et réprimer toutes les
personnes qui seraient dehors parce
qu'ils ne devraient pas l'être et je
pense que l'étape a pris en compte les
conditions spécifiques de certains
quartiers
je suis pas surpris par ce taux de
verbalisation mais je sais ça ça
conforte en tout cas l'idée que la
police aiment venir davantage de faire
du chiffre
chez nous qu'à paris je rappelle qu'à
paris récemment ça à danser sous un
balcon et des personnes n'ont pas été
verbalisé pour autant pour ce
département de la seine saint denis l'un
des territoires les plus touchés de
lille
france beaucoup ont aujourd'hui
l'impression que ces chiffres sont
révélateurs des inégalités dévoilée par
cette crise sanitaire et on fait le
point maintenant sur le bilan en europe
de l'épidémie de covile 19 l'espagne
enregistré moins de 300 morts ce jeudi
elle soit le bilan le plus faible depuis
le 20 mars dernier le pays compte
désormais 24 1500 morts de son côté
l'angleterre est devenue le troisième
pays le plus touché par le virus avec
674 décès sur les dernières 24 heures
portant le total à quasiment 27 mille
décès elle dans un discours boris
johnson a toutefois assuré que le pic de
l'épidémie était dépassée abaisse
également en italie avec 285 décès sur
les dernières 24 heures
le pays reste tout de même le deuxième
pays le plus touché au monde avec près
de 28 mille morts du virus l'europe elle
n'est pas encore sortie du confinement
mais la crise économique s'installe déjà
et les chiffres du premier trimestre ont
été annoncés pour plusieurs pays de
l'union
et sans surprise ils sont
catastrophiques on voit ce avec ighil
marosi et valentin carpentier
l'europe est officiellement entrée en
récession ce mercredi 30 avril il s'agit
de la pire récession depuis le premier
calcul de la croissance annuelle par
l'insee dans les années 1940
en france même en mai 68 les chiffres
étaient meilleurs au premier trimestre
de cette année folle le pib a chuté de
près de 6%
il faut remonter à 1940 pour assister à
un tel plongeon
car de nombreux secteurs sont touchés
restauration tourisme événementiel ou
encore aéronautique sont les plus
impactées par une crise qui aura des
conséquences à long terme
comme annoncé en mars dernier par le
ministre de l'économie bruno le maire et
des baisses de chiffre d'affaires de 60
% en moyenne pour les créateurs de 30 à
40% dans l'hôtellerie de 25% en moyenne
pour les restaurateurs et des chiffres
encore plus fort pour tout le secteur de
l'événementiel puisque les annulations
se font aujourd'hui en cascade
il y aura un avant et un après cette
épidémie de coronavirus sur
l'organisation de l'économie mondiale et
que nous voyons bien dans un certain
nombre de secteurs à quel point il est
important de réfléchir à une meilleure
organisation
en des chaînes de valeur à une
relocalisation de sion d'un certain
nombre d'activités stratégiques en
particulier dans le domaine de la santé
comme la france le reste de l'europe vit
une période économique sombre l'italie
notamment qui a sorti ses premiers
chiffres avec un pib en recul de 4,7
pour cent au premier trimestre c'est la
baisse la plus forte enregistrée par le
pays depuis 1995
c'est donc l'ensemble du pib de l'union
européenne qui s'effondre -3 8% pour la
zone euro et ces chiffres ne sont qu'un
avant goût car il reste désormais à
mesurer les effets du confinement sur le
pib pour avril et une partie du mois de
mai notamment pour les états qui ont
grondé confiné en dernier une situation
de force majeure qui contraint la
commission européenne a présenté un plan
de relance il y aura à coup sûr un
équilibre entre subventions et prêts
c'est une question de négociations entre
états membres pour trouver un mélange
équitable entre eux prêts et subventions
les deux ont des avantages et des
inconvénients vous connaissez les
arguments en faveur de chacun ils ont
été présentés ce soir de façon très
constructive
de l'autre côté de l'atlantique les
états unis ont renoué avec la récession
après plus d'une décennie de croissance
l'oncle sam a enregistré une chute de
son pib de 4 8%
tous les indicateurs sont en baisse ce
que reflète désormais les 26 millions de
chômeurs que compte le pays pour aider
l'économie à se relever
washington a débloqué 660 millions de
dollars de prêts non remboursables aux
pme à condition qu'elle concerne leurs
salariés dz coûteuse mais obligatoire
pour survivre au coït 19 et à une crise
économique il faudra juguler en europe
comme aux états unis et au vu de cette
récession en europe la banque centrale
européenne a pris la parole par le biais
de sa présidente christine lagarde a
pris la parole ce jeudi et a promis
d'utiliser tous les moyens de la banque
centrale européenne pour aider à
combattre cette crise sans précédent en
proposant déjà de racheter des dettes je
vous propose de l'écouter
la zone euro est confrontée à une
contraction économique d'une ampleur et
d'une rapidité sans
c'est dans tant de pays stagne oui oui
comme doc nous procéderons à des achats
d'actifs nets dans le cadre du programme
d'urgence de la banque centrale
européenne pour faire face à la pandémie
du coronavirus jusqu'à ce que le conseil
d'administration juge que la phase de
crise du coronavirus est terminée mais
en tout cas jusqu'à la fin de cette
année et pour en parler nous sommes avec
jean-philippe delsol avocats fiscalistes
et président du think tank européen iref
c'est l'institut de recherches
économiques et fiscales
jean-philippe delsol merci d'être avec
nous en direct sur rt france alors les
statistiques du premier trimestre 2009 1
commence à tomber et confirme les
craintes un partout la croissance
s'écroule cette chute de l'économie des
pays européens
elle va continuer bien sûr elle va
malheureusement continuer de manière
probablement encore significatifs voire
très significative
d'abord parce que le confinement a
continué dans la plupart des pays
européens encore au mois d'avril
peut-être au mois de mai pour un certain
nombre dont la france et le
déconfinement sera long lent et en fait
il sera très compliqué et difficile de
remettre les gens au travail
on a entendu christine lagarde à la
présidence de la banque centrale
européenne dire que l'europe allait
venir en aide financièrement aux pays
européens pour faire face à cette crise
est ce que les institutions européennes
ont les reins suffisamment solides
financièrement pour surmonter justement
cette crise économique
pour ma part je serais assez critique
sur la façon dont les choses sont
envisagés que dans la situation
d'urgence n y sommes il ait fallu
trouver les moyens de donner des
subventions aux salariés aux entreprises
qu'il ait fallu leur permettre
d'emprunter notamment pour les
entreprises
c'était nécessaire est normal mais par
contre ces solutions ne peuvent pas
durer
je voudrais simplement expliqué que si
la bce continue à déverser toujours plus
d'argent c'est à dire en fait si elle
crée de l'argent si elle imprime du
papier monnaie alors aujourd'hui on
n'imprime plus du papier monnaie
on dispense des crédits mais ça revient
au même si elle le fait de manière
extrêmement importante on parle de
centaines voire d'un millier de
milliards
c'est considérable et bien en fait on va
augmenter l'offre des individus et des
entreprises
on va par donges excusez moi on va
augmenter la demande des individus et
des entreprises sans augmenter l'offre
et donc on va créer des déséquilibres et
on va également répartir cette manne ce
qu'on appelle l'argent hélicoptère comme
s'ils ont distribué de l'argent par un
hélicoptère au profit de tout le monde
eh bien on va la distribuer de manière
discriminatoire et on va favoriser les
uns pénaliser les autres et en fait on
va créer des distorsions de marché c'est
à dire créer des situations qui aiment
ce qu'ils seront artificiel concernant
la distribution des richesses du porc ou
de distribution artificielle est
nuisible à terme parce qu'elle ne repose
pas sur des bases solides
du coup dans ce contexte là quels sont
les pays qui s'en sortiraient le mieux
c'est des pays qui se remettent très
vite au travail comme le souhaite bruno
le maire des pays qui vont relocaliser
leur production une relance de
l'économie ça va passer par où les pays
qui s'en sortiront le mieux sont ceux
qui était le mieux préparé
on pense notamment à l'allemagne par
exemple qui avec un taux de dépenses en
matière de santé à peu près équivalent à
celui de la france avec plus de lits de
réanimation plus d'équipement en matière
de tests en matière de masse et a pu
éviter un confinement l'on est
généralisée on pense aussi par exemple à
la suède
je parle des pays européens à la suède
qui a eu une option très différente de
celle des pays du sud
une option qu'ils renonçaient un
complément à un confinement généralisée
qui a laissé une certaine liberté pas
une liberté totale et qui s'en sort
semble-t-il beaucoup beaucoup mieux ces
pays là qui n'ont pas arrêté le travail
où il qu'ils n'ont pas arrêté
complètement le reprendront plus
et seront les meilleurs merci d'un oui
merci une phrase pour conclure vous
vouliez dire oui ce que je voudrais dire
pour conclure c'est que ça prouve tout
ça tout ce qui nous tout ce qui est en
train de nous arriver prouve que il faut
maintenir la concurrence entre les pays
européens
plutôt que de vouloir centraliser la
politique européenne
car cette concurrence entre pays
européens à cette diversité montre qu'il
ya des solutions différentes et permet
de choisir les meilleurs merci beaucoup
jean-philippe delsol d'avoir partagé
votre expertise je rappelle que vous
êtes avocat fiscaliste et président du
think tank européen iref acquis et
l'institut de recherches économiques et
fiscales 3 millions 8,2 nouveaux
demandeurs d'allocations chômage sur une
semaine aux états unis alors que
l'organisation mondiale de la santé
réunit son comité d'urgence
l'om est vivement critiquée par
washington qui lui a suspendu sa
contribution
l'amérique reste le foyer majeur de la
pandémie avec près de soixante deux
mille décès à new york
les pompes funèbres sont débordés
bernicot alisha connaît désormais la
rythmique parker depuis le début de la
pandémie
ce ballet incessant de brancards ne
faiblit pas manager d'un funérarium dans
le quartier d'harlem à new york
alisha essaye de ne refuser personne
quitte à se retrouver débordés
ce jour là ce sont de nouveaux corps qu
elle réceptionne de personnes décédées
des suites du coc vite 19
c'est dur pour moi de ne pas pouvoir
être au service des familles comme
j'aimerais l'être le plus dur c'est de
devoir refuser des gens donc j'essaye de
ne pas le faire et c'est pour ça qu'on
est si débordés de nombreuses personnes
sont mortes du coït bien sûr et donc les
familles sont en quarantaine et ne
viennent pas aux enterrements
alors il n'ya que nous l'employé des
pompes funèbres et la personne décédée
au cimetière donc on filme l'inhumation
et en envoie la vidéo à la famille et
c'est dur
les choses ont totalement changé si le
nombre de décès journaliers du corona
virus a été divisé par plus de deux par
rapport au pic de 799 morts enregistré
le 9 avril dernier à new york
les
pompes funèbres de la ville sont sous
tension et les employés sont souvent
témoins de scènes traumatisantes
il y a écrit qu'ovide qu'ovide 19 sur
les sacs mortuaires et ils sont empilés
sur des étagères dans certaines remorque
les corps sont à même le sol
il ya même certains employés certains
soignants qui ne veulent pas y mettre
les pieds
alors ils nous disent à nous les
employés des pompes funèbres d'y aller
pour trouver la personne décédée qu'on
doit prendre en charge et corps j'entre
il y a une mère de corps par terre et je
fais tout pour nos marchés sur personne
c'est traumatisant
la moitié des demandes que reçoit ce
funérarium concernent des victimes du
coronavirus ali shah et ses employés
sont obligés de travailler près de 80
heures par semaine contre 40
habituellement et ce 7 jours sur 7 les
gens sont désespérés ils nous disent ils
vont envoyer cette personne qui m'est
proche à la fosse commune l'hôpital ne
peut plus la garde et est ce que vous
pouvez m'aider et c'est si dur de leur
dire de rappeler dans deux jours ça me
brise le coeur
comme on peut le voir sur l'ordinateur
il y à tout un tas d'appels qu'on doit
encore traiter en va à brooklyn on va
dans le queens sauve à manhattan on va
dans le new-jersey on court partout pour
aller chercher les corps des personnes
décédées et notre sous-sol déborde on a
des boîtes en carton pour les crémations
direct empilées les unes sur les autres
c'est dur une scène douloureuse que cet
employé ne préfère pas montré à l'heure
actuelle la pandémie de corona virus a
causé à new york la mort de dix sept
mille personnes soit un habitant sur
cinq sens et contre le coronavirus un
nouveau traitement fait naître une lueur
d'espoir c'est leur md et viril
aurais-je site un effet net significatif
et positif selon une étude de
partenariat avec les instituts de santé
américain alors qu'en est-il vraiment
réponse en images
[Musique]
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et pour parler de ce traitement qui
suscite de l'espoir outre atlantique
nous sommes en direct de new york avec
vanessa acheteurs restent berg
journaliste indépendante c'est notre
rubrique vu de l'extérieur
[Musique]
vanessa schuster res berg merci d'être
avec nous en direct sur rt france alors
cette étude sur leur md y virent il faut
le rappeler 1 et qui existe deux essais
distincts avec cette molécule là aux
états unis donc et l'autre haouran en
chine
comment explique-t-on aux états unis que
les résultats sont plus concluants
finalement que se fait en chine
il s'agit du nombre des personnes qui
ont suivi ce traitement
beaucoup de personnes ont participé aux
essais biologiques chercheurs aux états
unis la moitié des personnes qui étaient
censés être testé en chine n'ont été que
lorsqu'on laisse songeur d'études
on a besoin d'avoir un certain nombre de
sujets pour avoir des résultats fiables
sur onze personnes qui étaient censés
être testé en chine 237 longtemps fait
était qu'il s'agit de résultats
significatifs exagéré docteur disque
les essais en aux états unis sont bien
plus viable alors en tout cas qu'est-ce
qui est relayée aujourd'hui quels sont
les effets observés sur les malades qui
ont recours à ce traitement
wagane des drag queens est encore en
train d'être testé donne et après les
résultats temporaire le temps de baisser
de plusieurs jours c'est ce qui donne de
l'espoir
on observe également une réduction de la
mortalité avec la prise de ce médicament
donc une moins deux morts et une
guérison plus rapide
alors vous le disiez les résultats
entier n'ont pas été encore publier la
prudence reste donc de rigueur est
néanmoins à ce que le sujet est devenu
politique aux etats unis
c'est une question intéressante c'est ax
u avec jean le connaissons une crise
économique
mallet historique à l'échelle de dessin
donc beaucoup de dirigeants ainsi que
monsieur trempe une approbation rapide
et l'utilisation que cette général la
réaction l'action et à l'intention de
naître un pari certes dans notre encadré
une approbation rapide de ce médicament
et pour que les etats unis se de nouveau
sur pied alors cette approbation rapide
indue du président donald trump
comment est-ce que cette volonté est
elle perçue par les citoyens
il ya beaucoup d'espoir qui est celle
concédée à médical en chef
c'est très positif et y attend tous les
états unis ses propos disant que si deux
doses étaient responsables ils ont
demandé si beaucoup de doses seraient
disponibles en janvier il a compté bien
sûr donc pour beaucoup de personnes le
réel désir c'est une lueur d'espoir face
à cette épidémie alors une lueur
d'espoir vous le disiez mais avec un
système de santé qui n'est ni universel
ni solidaire
est ce que tous les américains auraient
éventuellement accès à ce traitement
l'éthique est même l'objet d'essais
cliniques et la production suivra
également le serait disponible que pour
les personnes qui les plus vulnérables
donc il y aura des communication
permanente avec les hôpitaux pour sa
bière qui ferait se qualifiait pour ces
essais cliniques
elle ne souhaite également voir si les
enfants de moins de 18 ans les femmes
c'est dans le sens pourrait également
recevoir des médicaments en avance mais
comme je l'aï dit les essais sont en
cours et même s'il ya beaucoup d'espoir
nous ne sommes pas encore certains à de
la suite eh bien on suivra ça de près
ici depuis la france merci beaucoup en
tout cas vanessa szuster reste berg
d'avoir répondu à nos questions je
rappelle que vous êtes journaliste
indépendante en russie maintenant le
chef du gouvernement en israël michou
steen a été testé positif aux
coronavirus c'est le vice-premier
ministre andres beloussov qui assurera
l'intérim durant sa mise en isolement
alors que la russie a dépassé la barre
des cent mille cas le pays compte
désormais plus de 1000 morts mais n'a
toujours pas atteint le pic épidémique
selon les mots de vladimir poutine lundi
le chef du kremlin a annoncé une levée
progressive du confinement à partir du
12 mai et son ministre des affaires
étrangères salue les récents échanges de
prisonniers entre l'ukraine et les
républiques autoproclamées du nom basse
et de lougansk eux mais sergueï lavrov
appelle au respect du cessez le feu
conformément aux accords de minsk le
chef de la diplomatie russe s'est
exprimé à l'issue de la réunion en
visioconférence en format normandie avec
ses homologues ukrainiens français et
allemands ce chien avions encore une
fois à cette sensation fin juillet
franchement montré des statistiques sur
place et sa mission sur place
les bombardements de localisme des trucs
opposition poursuivre sa double cette
matière ces localités situées monsieur
votre sur le terrain pas seulement dans
l'autre sens du service tic appelée new
look et f
on its launch de neige supplémentaires
pour que le respect ça tu sais c'est le
jeu
et pour en parler nous sommes avec
l'autre blanchemaison expert en
relations internationales
claude blanchemaison merci d'être avec
nous sur rt france alors pourquoi les
ministres des affaires étrangères se
sont ils réunis par visioconférence en
format normandie aujourd'hui je crois
d'abord il est important de montrer que
la négociation continue ce n'est pas un
conflit gelé que nous avons dans basse
il y a un schéma de sortie qui est
l'accord a été conclu il ya cinq ans à
minsk et par conséquent beaucoup de
groupes de travail de groupe de contact
d'ailleurs continuent de se réunir
lorsqu'il y avait un sommet en format
normandie à paris le 9 décembre dernier
il avait été envisagé qu'un autre se met
lieu en avril donc maintenant ou en mai
à berlin
c'est évidemment impossible à cause de
la pandémie actuelle et les ministres
des affaires étrangères se sont réunis
pour faire le point par ailleurs
évidemment je pense que lille côté
ukrainien on était plutôt demandeurs
d'une réunion de ce genre
monsieur est un ski est soumis à de très
fortes pressions de la part des
partisans de son prédécesseur prochaine
co et puis des forces nationalistes dans
son pays qui l'accusent d'être trop
complaisants avec la russie et par
conséquent ils à être ou un intérêt où
sont menées des affaires étrangères
trouvent un intérêt à se faire faire le
point avec les français et les allemands
et avec et avec les russes par ailleurs
la france et l'allemagne souhaitent
aboutir à une solution et par conséquent
souhaité aussi que cette rencontre ait
lieu
quant à la russie monsieur servir vient
de s'exprimer et j'ai noté dans une
réponse à un journaliste il a beaucoup
insisté sur le fait qu' il fallait
surtout pas empêché les observateurs de
l'oaci eux de faire leur travail c'est à
dire de pouvoir circuler tout à fait
librement dans l'ensemble de l'ucal de
l'ukraine
10 y compris dans l'est de l'ukraine
c'est à dire dans le donbass
il a beaucoup insisté d'ailleurs au
cours de cette conférence de presse sur
le rôle que devait jouer
l'organisation de sécurité de
coopération en europe dans la la mise en
place d'une solution pour le dombass
dans l'est dans les bras dans la dans la
période qui vient alors qu'est ce que
claude blanche maison qu'est ce qu'on
pouvait attendre aujourd'hui comme avant
c'est un pendant cette réunion en format
normandie je crois que les ministres ont
fait là
la revue des différents volets le
premier étant évidemment les échanges de
prisonniers comme ça vient d'être dit il
faut en effet échangé tous les
prisonniers et l'accord de minsk jeudi
tous pour tous donc par conséquent tous
les prisonniers doivent être libérés
c'est compliqué parce que certains
peuvent être considérés comme des
prisonniers par un côté par pas par
l'autre donc c'est le travail de l'ouest
c'est eux c'est le travail des groupes
de contacts qui existe à ce sujet de
faire tout ce travail technique pour
libérer tous les prisonniers
deuxièmement très important et je vois
aps les ministres en ont beaucoup parlé
le cessez le feu n'est pas respecté
monsieur lavrov a expliqué qu' il y
avait des bombardements et craignent
enfin les ukrainiens explique aussi
qu'il ya des morts dans l'armée
ukrainienne
par conséquent les deux côtés ce
accusent de ne pas respecter le cessez
le feu et il est très important que ce
cessez-le-feu soit respectée notamment
en retirant de plusieurs kilomètres les
armes lourdes et également des troupes
qui de chaque côté sont avec ses
armements
alors c'est important d'autant plus
qu'actuellement c'est un peu dérisoire
de jouer à une petite guerre autour de
cette ligne de cessez le feu qui remonte
à une guerre diagne
quatre ou cinq ans qui a fait quand même
quatorze mille morts et aujourd'hui où
il ya cette pandémie qui risque
d'ailleurs de faire des dégâts dans dans
les dents l'état dans l'est dans les
derniers dans les rangs des militaires
il soit ukrainiens ou qu'ils
appartiennent aux républiques
autoproclamées du de neige le loup ans
et que par conséquent il est
probablement temps de faire taire les
armes
par ailleurs effectivement les les
ministres se sont penchés sur
l'aggravation des problèmes humanitaires
et je viens d'y faire allusion avec la
diffusion du coronavirus bien sûr des
deux côtés le conte un virus ne connaît
pas de ligne de cessez-le-feu ne connaît
pas de frontières et une situation
humanitaire qui est en train de se
dégrader dans le dans le dans le donbass
et puis bien sûr il ya l'appel au
dialogue direct entre les autorités de
kiev et les autorités de fait du dombass
c'est à dire de loin qui le donnait pour
définir les modalités dans lesquels en
cours à réaliser des élections
là dessus il ya évidemment une
divergence entre moscou et kiev puisque
kiev demande le retrait de tous les les
troupes qui serait là en soutien des
deux républiques autoproclamées et la
russie dit qu'il n'y a pas de troupes
russes
par conséquent on doit trouver un modus
vivendi pour que dans le cadre d'une
décentralisation
ces deux régions puissent continuer à
parler le russe ilia le souhaitent et
qu'elle puisse élire leurs représentants
dans le cadre de la nation ukrainienne
puisque personne ne conteste que ces
deux provinces appartiennent à l'ukraine
merci merci beaucoup claude blanche
maison pour votre analyse rappelle que
vous êtes expert en relations
internationales et dans quelques
instants nous reviendrons sur le plan de
déconfinement du gouvernement qui va se
déployer à partir du 11 mai en france
ensuite nous aurons la chronique de
l'économiste jacques sapir il répondra à
la question comment redresser l'économie
tout en contenant l'épidémie de kobe de
une équation qui s'annonce délicat
à thé enfin nous prendront la direction
de la libye avec tripoli qui rejette la
trêve annoncée par le maréchal haftar
rester avec nous sur rt france
[Musique]
quelles conséquences du coronavirus sur
le sport d'un point de vue sanitaire
économique et sociale on en parle avec
vous invitez gervais martel ex président
du racing club de lens et christophe le
petit économiste du sport
on ne reprendra pas le sport
professionnel dans des conditions
normales il n'y a que le football
aujourd'hui qui restent encore accrocher
à cet espoir de pouvoir finir la saison
on joue humble le tout trop fondre dans
les dents les stinky parmi les autres
sports professionnels français
tous ont pris la décision de ne pas
jouer que la crise touche tout le monde
il combinera route il au sujet de
réflexion pour revenir à plus de mesure
et faire en sorte de construire en fait
un business qui sera aussi plus durable
éco des milieux peuvent être pleinement
certains frais aux deux voies qui
transitent les filles de sport c'est la
rue donc si on peut retrouver tout ce
qui est des terrains libres et pour le
pauvre passion savoure à dire qu'à vivre
denis normal
[Musique]
ici on écrire ce qu'ils ne sont pas
d'accord
ici on invite les plus compétents pas
seulement ceux qui parlent le plus fort
[Musique]
ici on reçoit c'est qu'on ne voit pas
ailleurs
[Musique]
parce qu'ici c'est interdit d'interdire
vous vous dites que ce délit de
violation du confinement n'est pas
conforme à la constitution comme un e
ceux des comptes revient à 1 ou un 2
principes majeurs sont celui du concept
d'égalité des délits td et le principe
de 40 km/h et de première nécessité
quelques lignes familiales impérieuses
j'ai finalement délaissé à la libre
appréciation de l'agent et ça ne nous
prêts mais ne pas emprunter ce code
arbitre il sortait la teneur déclaré
qu'il ne dit pas qu'il y ait des
terreurs et c'est parce que je ne
doutais pas qu'il y ait veillé à ce que
le délai des pompes des stations et à 4
ans et et c'est là où la présomption
d'innocence n'est pas respectée d'état
[Musique]
problème
on vit tous les jours sans faire
attention que tout en dépend c'est
l'unité de mesure de toute chose une
convention and who is par tous s'il
arrive quelque chose tout s'arrête
[Applaudissements]
vous conviendrez que c'est l'argent qui
fait tourner le monde
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
peu importe que ce soit des bitcoins ou
du bon vieux cash
nous vous parlerons de tout sans langue
de bois
[Musique]
bonsoir et merci de nous rejoindre pour
une nouvelle demi heure d'information il
est 21h heure de paris tout de suite les
titres de l'actualité de ce jeudi 30
avril 2011 comment remettre les français
au travail sans déclencher une deuxième
vague de l'épidémie le gouvernement a
présenté ce soir sa carte de france avec
des départements en vert jaune et rouge
le coronavirus qui a fait 2 189 victimes
ces dernières 24 heures dans ce contexte
edouard philippe a consulté des
partenaires sociaux cet après midi alors
que les chiffres de l'économie sont
alarmants le pib a chuté de 5 8% pour le
seul premier trimestre redresser
l'économie tout en contenant l'épidémie
de kobe 19 l'équation s'annonce délicate
pour le gouvernement dans son plan de
déconfinement edouard philippe a insisté
sur la nécessaire reprise du travail dès
le 11 mai prochain
quitte à favoriser le télétravail à
l'heure où plus de 11 millions de
salariés sont au chômage partiel
quelle sortie crise peut-on envisager un
retour à la normale est il possible
où va-t-on vers une explosion du chômage
autant de questions auxquelles
l'économiste jacques sapir tentera de
répondre tout à l'heure dans sa
chronique etc
[Musique]
en libye à tripoli rejette la trêve
annoncée par le maréchal haftar l'homme
fort de l'est du pays a annoncé la nuit
dernière la cessation des opérations
militaires à l'occasion du ramadan un
mais il prévient que la réponse sera
très dur en cas de violation de l'autre
camp lundi il avait déclaré prendre le
pouvoir pour gouverner seul le p
[Musique]
voici le dernier bilan en france est
liée aux comics 19 le pays déplore
aujourd'hui 24 1376 décès à la direction
générale de la santé a annoncé ces
dernières 24 heures une hausse du nombre
de morts avec 289 nouveaux décès on
relève par ailleurs une baisse du nombre
de personnes en réanimation avec 188
patients en est la fête du travail
célèbre et un brin de muguet célébrer
avec un brin de muguet différemment avec
chris du coronavirus oblige aucun
rassemblement ne peut avoir lieu dans
les rues du pays
une première depuis 75 ans alors comment
les syndicats comptent ils se mobiliser
pour l'occasion éléments de réponse avec
nadja de grazac c'est du jamais vu
depuis la seconde guerre mondiale il n'y
aura pas de défilé syndical ce 1er mai
l'an dernier la mobilisation avait réuni
salariés et gilet jaune
ils étaient entre 150 milles et 300000
partout en france
pourtant malgré le confinement pas
question pour les syndicats de manquer
ce rendez vous traditionnel
nous porterons ce 1er mai 2020 bien que
confiné les revendications qui sont plus
que jamais d'actualité
sacrifier la santé des travailleurs
n'est pas admissible sacrifier les
droits des travailleurs sur l'autel de
l'économie n'est pas tolérable et ne
pourra continuer quelle que soit la
situation
sacrifier les plus précaires d'entre
nous n'est pas admissible dans une
société d'égalité et de solidarité
situation sanitaire oblige
la mobilisation doit se réinventer
manifestation sur la toile où depuis sa
fenêtre ou son balcon tous les moyens
sont bons pour manifester ailleurs que
dans la rue va falloir s'habituer à ce
qu'il y ait d'autres modes de
fonctionnement social et politique
on sait très bien que les grandes
révolutions ce soit dans les printemps
arabes ou ailleurs ont été déclenchées
initiés porte est alimenté par par les
réseaux sociaux donc c'est pas une
nouveauté bon le fait et c'est que
demain ça va remplacer complètement des
rassemblements qui avaient aussi lieu
dans l'espace dans l'espace public donc
je pense que évidemment pour beaucoup
c'est une parenthèse dans une vie
sociale qui chacun l'espère reprendra
son rythme normal un petit peu un petit
peu plus tard paradoxalement c'est assez
symbolique qu'on célèbre demain une fête
du travail alors que plus de 10 millions
de personnes sont en chômage partiel que
probablement beaucoup licencié ne
retrouveront pas leur activité
donc ça peut être aussi une sorte
d'appel au travail
1une fait de la lutte contre le chômage
l'association réaction 19 qui prépare
l'après qu'ovide 19 avait par exemple
prévu un rassemblement ce 1er mai au
trocadéro elle s'est rapidement vu
notifier une interdiction de manifester
par la préfecture de police de paris
une décision qualifiée d'injuste par le
président de l'association
nous avons écrit que les personnes
allaient s'installer sur le parvis avec
une distance de à mettre demi deux
mètres chacun portant des gants et
portant des masques à respectant ce
qu'on appelle les gestes barrière g10
est mauvais il y aura peut-être le
premier mais des personnes qui vont
s'arrêter y restera un silence pendant
une heure pour appeler les victimes de
coups et 19
c'est une atteinte aux principes
essentiels de la liberté d'aller et
venir de la liberté de circuler de la
liberté d'expression de la liberté de
manifester parce que le confinement tels
qu'ils étaient conçus en france il était
adopté
parce qu'il n'ya pas les lits
nécessaires et une structure
hospitalière qui pouvait affronter
retraite pouvoir d'achat égalité sociale
est désormais chômage de masse s'il est
impossible de se rassembler en ces temps
de confinement le mois de septembre
s'annonce d'ores et déjà placé sous le
signe des revendications sociales et
pour en parler nous sommes avec alexis
poulain cofondateur du monde moderne
alexis poulain merci d'être avec nous
sur ert france alors pour commencer est
ce que le gouvernement aurait pu
accepter pour le 1er mai des
rassemblements avec bien entendu le
respect des consignes sanitaires est ce
que cela aurait pu être quelque chose de
faisable ou en tout cas symbolique oui
bien sûr c'était quelque chose de tout à
fait faisable on a vu des manifestations
de ce type en israël où les distances de
sécurité a été respectée manifestations
contre la corruption des gouvernants
donc c'est un choix volontaire de dire
on fait le choix de la précaution bien
entendu en une fois encore ne faisant
pas confiance aux uns et aux autres de
respecter les gestes barrière alors les
syndicats qui ont rencontré edouard
philippe
aujourd'hui selon vous remettre
rapidement les français au travail
quelles garanties doivent être assurés
bien les garanties c'est de préserver
les droits des travailleurs parce qu'on
a vu ces dernières semaines des attaques
en règle de la part des syndicats
patronaux le medef en tête pour casser
les 35 heures pour faire en sorte que et
bien finalement les les jours de congés
soit diminuée pour sauver l'économie
française avec ce rêve de semaine de
travail de 60 heures pourquoi pas dans
les secteurs clés donc vraiment d'une
poussée du du syndicat patronal pour
essayer de casser encore davantage le
code et le droit du travail et puis
l'autre chose aussi où il faut être
vigilant
c'est que le ministère du travail ne
soutient pas les inspecteurs du travail
il y à une pétition qui tourne en ce
moment pour soutenir un inspecteur du
travail qui a été mise à pied pour
simplement faire son travail et dire que
les salariés d'une entreprise n'était
pas protégé lorsque celle ci était en
activité au pic de la crise le ministère
du travail ça doit devenir le ministère
des travailleurs ce qui va se passer
avec le déconfinement ce que l'on trouve
ce virus c'est que la lutte des classes
n'a jamais été aussi vivace n'a jamais
été d'une telle intensité
il ya ceux qui sont en première ligne
les invisibles ceux qui ne sont rien
selon emmanuel macron à kiel dit merci
quotidiennement les caissiers les
éboueurs les gens qui sont là qui font
tenir cette économie parce que il ne
demande rien et qu'il travaille au
quotidien
ces gens là dans la crise sera finie et
bien ce sera une ligne sur un tableau
excel et les décideurs les néo manager
les managers et bien les dires rond pour
sauver les profits des actionnaires
donc il est important que les syndicats
soient conscients que aujourd'hui plus
que jamais la lutte des classes est
d'actualité et qu'ils sont responsables
pour tenir les droits des travailleurs
face à une attaque sans précédent des de
ces droits là alors il ya des syndicats
qui ont brandi la carte du droit de
retrait notamment concernant la
réouverture dans les écoles est ce qu'un
mouvement pourra imaginer qu'un
mouvement social finalement s'invite
dans la stratégie du déconfinement
évidemment je pense c'est la peur même
de l'exécutif
imaginez un déconfinement politique
imaginez un déconfinement sociale et
solidaire imaginaire déconfinement avec
des procès pour leur responsabilité dans
cette gestion calamiteuse de la crise
vouloir mettre les français au travail
très bien parce que derrière évidemment
on ne peut pas accepter la faillite de
40% de restaurants où vient la faillite
de et pme en france mais pas à n'importe
quel prix
je pense que c'est extrêmement important
que les syndicats jouent le rôle à plein
c'est à dire de protéger les droits des
travailleurs parce que l'économie ne
doit pas être fait aux dépens des
travailleurs c'est eux qui sont les
créateurs de valeur ses yeux par leur
travail par le quotidien qui font que ça
tourne qui font que eh bien les rentiers
peuvent bénéficier de leur rente
il faut simplement rééquilibrer regardez
la folie idéologique de ce gouvernement
qui refuse de remettre lisf sur la table
qui refuse de faire payer les plus
riches leur part juste au gâteau en
disant vous avez bénéficié de ce système
c'est à vous maintenant de redonner au
commun et qui préfèrent vendre et bien
les bijoux de famille avec le mobilier
national et autres pour trouver un peu
d'argent pour l'hôpital
on est dans un scandale idéologiques
sans fin son nom et il a ma peur est la
peur de beaucoup c'est que cette sortie
de crise en fête ouvre les vannes en
fait dernier au libéralisme encore plus
violent que ce qu'on a connu auparavant
où finalement la captation du profit et
l'exploitation des uns par les autres
ban va être encore plus violente que
auparavant merci beaucoup alexis poulain
je rappelle que vous êtes co fondateur
du monde moderne redresser l'économie
tout en contenant l'épidémie de kovy 19
l'équation s'annonce donc délicate pour
le gouvernement dans son plan de
déconfinement et loire philippaerts
insisté sur la nécessaire reprise du
travail dès le 11 mai prochain on en
parlait quitte à favoriser le
télétravail
à l'heure où plus de 11 millions de
salariés sont au chômage partiel quelle
sortie crise peut-on envisager un retour
à la normale est il possible où va-t-on
vers une explosion du chômage
on voit cela tout de suite avec
l'économiste jacques sapir que l'on
retrouve via skype aujourd'hui encore
bienvenue jacques alors jacques le
gouvernement fait face à un véritable
choix cornélien n'est ce pas oui
absolument
on a compris dans les annonces faites
par edouard philippe à l'assemblée
nationale que la stratégie du
gouvernement est donc de remettre la
france au plus vite au travail tout en
évidence que l'on appelle la deuxième
vague
c'est à dire en réalité une résurgence
explosive de l'épidémie mais cela
confronte au gouvernement un véritable
dilemme alors que le confinement est en
train en réalité de détruire l'économie
française comment éviter le pire
alors que certains de nos voisins en
particulier l'allemagne des confine bien
plus vite que nous alors peut-être
jacques tout d'abord est-ce que vous
pouvez nous dresser un tableau de l'état
de l'économie française après un mois et
demi de confinement vous avez tout à
fait raison olivier ses parents cela
qu'il faut commencer et bien
actuellement nous savons que +2 55% des
salariés du secteur privé sont en
chômage partiel
l'économie tourne donc au ralenti en
dessous en réalité 2 50% de son activité
normale alors comme on peut le voir sur
le tableau qui s'affiche
lindsay avait fait des estimations qui
était relativement optimiste à la
du mois de mars elle a réitéré ses
estimations au début du mois d'avril
dans mon propre laboratoire au s'est mis
nous étions déjà nettement plus
pessimiste et la différence venait de ce
que nous avions tout d'abord cherché à
estimer la perte en productivité induite
par le télétravail
ce que n'a pas fait l'insee est que nous
pensions aussi que la contraction du
secteur des services était bien plus
importante que ce que l'insee estimé
c'est ce qui peut expliquer probablement
que l'insee et le gouvernement
avec cet institut et eu tendance à
sous-estimer l'ampleur de la crise à
venir du moins jusqu'à ces derniers
jours il pour essayer pour ce qui est de
l'impact sur l'emploi pôle emploi
annonce une nette remontée du chômage en
mars 2020 oui oui oui absolument
les chiffres du premier trimestre pour
les demandeurs d'emploi sont en train de
repartir à la hausse et cela pour toutes
les catégories
alors pour les deux catégories qui sont
réellement les plus représentatifs du
chômage on voit que il y à une remontée
alors que ce soit pour la fameuse
catégorie ya mais aussi pour les
catégories bd qui sont des catégories
très proche de la catégorie a et cette
augmentation est tout à fait sensible en
particulier sur le mois de mars
alors il faut dire là et c'est une chose
importante que les mesures du mois de
mars ont en réalité été marqué par tout
ce qui s'est passé dans la deuxième
quinzaine du mois de mars
donc ce que l'on pense comme une
remontée elle elle est concentrée sur
les deux dernières semaines de mars
alors jacques notre économie et donc en
grande partie à l'arrêt est-ce que cela
compte pour le plan de déconfinement ah
oui absolument olivier c'est tout à fait
évident ainsi on peut penser que la
décision du premier ministre de rouvrir
les crèches et des écoles communales a
pour véritable but en réalité de libérer
les parents et de leur permettre de
reprendre le travail
d'ailleurs
rappelez dans de nombreux autres pays
comme par exemple l'italie ou le royaume
uni
les écoles ne rouvriront qu'en septembre
et dans ceux qui ont décidé de rouvrir
leur école dès maintenant à peu près en
même temps que nous et bien en réalité
fait rentrer plus tôt les lycéens des
grandes places dont on peut
raisonnablement estimer dont on peut
attendre qu'ils respecteront eux les
fameux gestes barrière alors jacques ce1
et confinement qu'edouard philippe a
annoncé comme est très progressif
peut-il permettre d'empêcher une forte
montée du chômage dans les mois à venir
dont olivier hélas non et vous avez
raison d'ailleurs de dire que le
déconfinement tel qu'il a été proposé
par le premier ministre sera très
progressive et cela aura d'ailleurs des
conséquences importantes sur l'économie
alors ici encore nous avons cherché au
s'est mis à simuler l'impact du
déconfinement de l'économie et nous
sommes arrivés en fait à trois cours à
la première cour la courbe eu un qui est
en bleu correspond aux prévisions du
gouvernement elle donne une chute du pib
de moins 10% pour l'ensemble de l'année
2020 et elle suppose que l'économie
française retrouvera son niveau d'avant
le confinement en trois mois seulement
nous considérons que ces prévisions sont
encore nettement trop optimistes alors
nous avons proposé une ou deux autres
courbes eu 2 et 3 qui simule tout
d'abord un arrêt de plus important de
l'économie pendant la période du
confinement et un retour à l'activité
qui sera nettement plus lent elle donne
des baisse du pib allant de -10 % à -
douze ennemis % pour 2020
et si pour la courbe eux deux celle qui
est en orange
le retour à la normale pourrait avoir
lieu vers la fin de l'année
grosso modo le mois d'octobre ou le
dégoût le début du mois de novembre n'en
a pas du tout de même pour la cour de 3
selon cette dernière la récession
induite justement par le confinement
pourrait année au moins jusqu'au premier
semestre de 2021 alors du coup jacques
on imagine que cela aura des
conséquences sur les chiffres du chômage
oui tout à fait tout à fait olivier un
retour bien plus lent à l'activité
normale va mettre en péril
de très nombreuses sociétés qu'elles
soient petites ou qu'elle soit grande
sur les 11 millions de personnes qui
sont aujourd'hui au chômage partiel
un certain nombre ne retrouveront pas
leur emploi alors on va prendre trois
quarts tout d'abord le secteur de la
restauration et de l'hôtellerie
c'est un secteur qui emploie en gros
près d'un million de personnes
nous craignons ici que le tiers d'entre
elles ne se retrouvent au chômage
avec la fin du confinement et du système
de chômage partiel qui a d'ailleurs été
annoncé comme devant prendre fin au
début du mois de juin
alors si on prend maintenant un deuxième
secteur à secteurs à haute technologie
comme l'industrie aéronautique et le
transport aérien
ici aussi les perspectives sont
mauvaises airbus pourrait mettre au
chômage près de 3000 salariés et au delà
si on accepte les prévisions qui sont
faites par les grandes compagnies
aériennes l'activité de ce secteur ne
retrouverait son niveau normal que d'ici
deux à trois ans enfin dans l'automobile
qui est aussi un secteur important pour
l'économie française
la baisse de la demande pourrait
contraindre tout le secteur à réduire la
voilure de manière considérable bref des
dizaines et des dizaines de milliers
d'emplois seront perdus et encore plus
si l'on tient compte évidemment de
l'ensemble des sous-traitants et peut-on
chiffrer cet impact de la crise sur
l'emploi
alors oui oui on peut on peut
effectivement olivier entre les
nombreuses petites et moyennes
entreprises qui ne survivront pas un
déconfinement très progressif et
entreprises qui ne pourront elles
survivre qu'au prix d'une réduction
importante de leur activité
on peut penser que d'ici la fin de
l'année une hausse du chômage d'au moins
500 mille personnes voire plus sera
inévitable alors si nous avions à la fin
de 2019 environ 4,3 millions de
demandeurs d'emploi au chômage et 1,7
million de personnes qui étaient dans
une situation d'emploi de très grande
précarité
eh bien on peut craindre qu'à la fin de
ne soyons autour de 4,8 millions de
personnes au chômage et de 2 à 2,2
millions de personnes qui se retrouvent
dans cette situation d'emploi
extrêmement précaire ce qui veut dire
que l'ensemble des personnes dépendantes
de pôle emploi pourrait avoisiner les 7
millions en décembre 2020 autrement dit
cent mille personnes de plus que ce que
nous avions au deuxième trimestre de
2010 est c'est à dire au moment où
emmanuel macron a été ainsi jacques et
pour conclure après la vague de
l'épidémie il faut s'attendre à la vague
du chômage
oui c'est hélas exactement la situation
alors il faut comprendre que nous sommes
dans une crise qui est à double détente
nous sommes aujourd'hui dans un moment
sanitaire de cette crise
mais ce moment sanitaire ne doit pas
masquer évidemment l'arrivée d'un moment
économique qui sera extrêmement
important et là il faut avoir toujours à
l'esprit le fait que oui bien sûr
cette épidémie on pourra tuer beaucoup
de gens peut-on plus de toutes
conditions sociales
il ya eu les députés comme patrick
devedjian ou même des chanteurs connus
comme christophe sauf que la crise
économique qui vient en tueur a aussi
beaucoup mais de cela on en parlera
moins six tentées même que l'on en parle
et
ce que ce seront que c'est noir et bien
ce seront les morts de la france
ouvrière les morts de la france active
les morts de la france périphérique
le confinement a eu sol tout comme effet
de protéger la france des centres villes
la france des métropoles et c'était
nécessaire
on ne le conteste pas mais il faut
comprendre que c'est la france
périphérique qui va prendre à elle seule
le choc de la crise économique qui vient
merci jacques pour toutes ces
explications et réalise très réaliste
des conséquences de cette crise sur
l'emploi
à très bientôt sur rt france jacques
merci à vous olivier elle crie poli
rejette la trêve annoncée par le
maréchal haftar le gouvernement d'union
nationale indique dans un communiqué
qu'il poursuivrait sa défense légitime à
la nuit dernière son rival l'homme fort
de l'est l'idée a annoncé la cessation
des opérations militaires à l'occasion
du ramadan
il ya une semaine l'onu l'union
européenne ainsi que plusieurs autres
pays dont la russie et avaient appelé à
cette trêve précision avec valentin
carpentier et david khalifa scènes de
liesse à bengazi les partisans du
général haftar laissent exploser leur
joie après son allocution qui s'inscrit
dans l'histoire du pays
welvaert la baignoire vélo v nous sommes
fiers du mandat du peuple pour cette
mission historique dans ces
circonstances exceptionnelles et nous
annonçons la fin de l'accord politique
ferrer avait révélé sa taille huayra
fait la malle et bb&t va passer assez i
suite à une décision du peuple libyen la
source de tous les pouvoirs à l'armée
lachaab élévé massarotto la map
nous acceptons la volonté du peuple et
son mandat les convois quels mots sales
draps
les airs à dater chat un soulagement
pour la plupart des libyens
malgré le confinement ils ont tenu à
célébrer cette annonce exprimer leur
soutien indéfectible à leur leader le
peuple demande le soutien aux forces
militaires arabe libyenne dirigé par le
maréchal khalifa becker 6 9
la demande du pape est bien connu oui
aux dirigeants lui au maréchal oui au
sang des martyrs
oui aux blessés oui à la libye de rass
ajdir à ben saad
dans sa déclaration le maréchal haftar
qui contrôlent l'est et une partie du
sud du pays indiqué mettre un terme aux
accords de skhirat portant sur les
conditions de paix dans le pays à des
propos qui ont beaucoup fait réagir le
pouvoir à tripoli
le gouvernement d'union nationale a
dénoncé un nouveau coup d'état en
reprochant au maréchal haftar de vouloir
mettre en place une dictature
dix ans après celle de mouammar kadhafi
c'est une farce et un nouveau coup
d'état qui s'ajoute à une longue série
le maréchal haftar veut dissimuler la
défaite de ses milices et mercenaires et
l'échec de son projet dictatorial la
communauté internationale est également
réagi aux propos de l'homme fort de
l'est libyen notamment la russie par le
biais de son ministre des affaires
étrangères sergueï lavrov qui indiquait
ne pas approuver cette déclaration et
auquel les états unis et l'union
européenne ont emboîté le pas alors que
le monde s'évertue à combattre le
courreau dhabi russe la libye de son
côté demeure plongée dans un conflit qui
ne cesse de s'aggraver pandémie ou pas
et pour en parler nous sommes avec jalel
harchaoui chercheurs aux clichés d'elle
institute de la javel harchaoui merci
d'être avec nous sur rt france alors le
gouvernement d'union nationale on le
disait a rejeté aujourd'hui la très
voulu par le général haftar pendant le
mois de ramadan c'était prévisible
oui c'était prévisible qu'il qu'il
demande un cessez le feu ou au moment où
justement ces difficultés commencent à
devenir réellement aiguë est difficile à
affronter
et c'est aussi prévisible que dans ces
moments où où les landes une escalade
qui est prévu par la turquie depuis
quatre mois
évidemment on ne peut pas être arrêtée
maintenant
donc c'est une espèce de valse à
laquelle on assiste avec ce mot clé de
pause humanitaire ou de cessez le feu
mais ce n'est pas ce n'est pas
véritablement mais table en oeuvre ni
d'un côté ni de l'autre même haftar
réellement arrêter ces hommes en
tripolitaine l'élan est juste trop grand
et ça n'aurait où ça ne répond à aucun
réalisme ce genre de propos que la
raison pour laquelle je pense que c'est
prévisible c'est parce qu'il en a besoin
il a besoin d'un cessez le feu pour
retrouver ses forces regroupées ses
hommes accumulé un peu plus
d'équipements qu'ils attendent notamment
de la part des émirats arabes unis
peut-être récolter des mercenaires
supplémentaires qu'ils essaient
d'obtenir depuis plusieurs semaines et
c'est pour cela qu'il demande un cessez
le feu c'est aussi une occasion pour
crier à quel point on peut diaboliser
comme ça la turquie et le gouvernement
d'entente nationale
c'est un jeu mais cela veut dire que
quand le général tard promet une réponse
très rude et immédiate en cas de
violation de cette trêve par le le gêne
à ce que vous nous dites c'est que
finalement il n'a pas les moyens de
cette riposte rude et immédiate il n'y a
pas un moyen de jade d'arrêter les
hostilités mène de son côté à lui
d'ailleurs ne sont pas arrêtées pendant
toutes les les annonces qu'on entend
depuis hier mais les hostilités de la
part de ses hommes en continu et on
comprend parce qu'ils sont coincés dans
des situations qui ne sont pas stables
et évidemment les hommes du gouvernement
d'entente nationale continuent leur
opération ils vont pas s'arrêter
maintenant alors que ça fait des mois
des mois qu'ils y travaillent aider des
millions d'euros qui ont été dépensés
pour justement la mise en place de cette
france de cette contre offensive de
tripoli le fait de menacer le
gouvernement d'entente nationale en cas
de non respect du cessez le feu oui vous
avez raison c'est absolument absurde
parce que c'est quelqu'un qui en
difficulté militaire je ne dis pas qu'il
est en train de s'écrouler
je ne dis pas que c'est fini pour lui
mais il sa situation est inquiétante et
c'est pour cela qu'on a assisté à cette
prise de pouvoir il ya quelques jours
dans l'est de la libye ce parce qu'il se
sent en danger il a peur qu'on le
remplace il a peur que des états comme
la russie se met à parler de plus en
plus à d'autres figures de l'est de la
libye de la cyrénaïque et qu'il perdrait
comme ça tout toute valeur politique et
qui le sombrerait dans l'oubli ça c'est
un risque qu'il a réussi à réduire en
faisant de l'ombre en éclipsant les
institutions civiles qui existaient qui
l'ont soutenue au cours de cette demi
décennie depuis 2015 2014 le soutiennent
ce mais c'est à cause de ces difficultés
là qui s'est senti menacé qu'il a dû
prendre un peu plus de pouvoir effacer
donc les quelques institutions civiles
qui existait à l'est c'est la version
wii pourquoi en cure il nous reste très
peu de temps à haut niveau international
on disait la russie qui était soutien du
général haftar a pris ses distances
mardi dernier en affirmant ne pas
approuver la balade sa déclaration selon
laquelle il décidera unilatéralement est
la façon dont le peuple libyen vivre à
cette prise de position de la russie
peut être changer la donne oui là la
russie par ce cas là la force si vous
voulez la force du réaliste la force de
caractère de d'une entité tout à fait
réaliste et qui ne se prend pas au jeu
idéologique des uns et des autres à la
possibilité comme ça et c'est ce à quoi
on assiste assez frappant de dire que
haftar est un acteur qui doit se prêter
aux conditions de ses parents et le
parent peut être le plus important dans
cette a7 à ce moment charnière
c'est la russie qui peut effectivement
changé de camp elle peut moduler son
soutien elle peut retirer certains
soutiens militaires certains soutiens
économiques mêmes qui sont assez vitaux
pour le maraîcher resta et toute cette
marge de manoeuvre ni les états
ni la france ni les émirats arabes unis
non ce type de marge de manoeuvre dont
ça c'est frappant maire de voir le
réalisme de poutine à l'oeuvre merci
beaucoup je harchaoui d'avoir partagé
votre analyse je rappelle que vous êtes
chercheur au avec les jeunes des
l'institute delahaye et c'est la fin de
cette édition un peu écourtée en raison
du coronavirus et comme tous les médias
nous sommes contraints de réduire nos
programmes
prochain point complet sur l'actualité
ce sera demain à 8 heures heure de paris
bon courage à tous et excellente soirée
sur arte france
[Musique]